good morning everyone and welcome to the
new series in cyber security
in this series we are going to discuss
about the interview questions that will
be asked
to candidates in the cyber security
field
we are going to look at multiple options
over here
and we are going to discuss various
fields in which these questions will be
asked
in this video we are going to look at 10
different questions on networking
then we'll have 10 more questions on
software and programming
another 10 questions on operating
systems and applications
10 questions on cyber attacks and then
the finally
10 questions on cryptography so we're
going to discuss over 50 odd questions
each in these different fields which
will help you crack your
interviews as far as cyber security is
concerned let's start off with
networking questions
let's start off with question one what
is the osi model
explain the different layers of the osi
model osi largely is a theoretical model
uh utilized to understand networking and
how data packets are created
and how they are being processed by a
computer
this is normally used by the tcp the
transmission control protocol over
internet protocol
software suite so osi
is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model
that describes how applications are
going to interact via the computer
network
there are seven different layers that we
need to understand
they are as follows so in this diagram
there are these seven different layers
we start off from the bottom first is
the physical
layer the data link layer network layer
transport layer
session layer presentation and
application when
such a question is asked in an interview
it is not only that we identified these
seven layers explaining what the osi
model is in the first place
we then try to identify these seven
layers and we give a
brief description about each and every
layer if there are any additional
questions they will come after
this basic question so let's start off
with the physical layer
this is the lowest layer of the osi
model now this is where
any and every physicality of your
computer comes into the picture
so it could be a network interface card
it could be an rj45 or a
cat5 cable anything that allows data to
be transmitted
physically from your machine to another
machine
next comes the data link layer so on the
data link layer as far as networking is
concerned we just need to understand
that
data packet is encoded decoded into bits
at this layer
this is also the layer that deals with
mac addressing so the physical address
of every
network interface card which is the mac
address which is utilized to
route data packets over the network this
is where the mac address resides on the
data link layer
the next layer is the network layer here
datagrams are transferred from one to
another
the function of this layer are routing
and logical addressing the moment we
talk about
routing and logical addressing ip
addresses come into the picture ipv4 ip
version 6.
so network layer will deal with ip
addressing and the routing of those
packets then comes the transport layer
this is the layer responsible for
end-to-end connections
that automatically signifies that this
is where tcp and udp will be working
tcp stands for transmission control
protocol udp for user datagram protocol
tcp is a connection oriented protocol
whereas udp is a connectionless protocol
these two protocols are utilized
to establish connectivity between two
machines
tcp is a more reliable method of
connectivity because there are a lot of
packets that are sent across to verify
that the data has been sent
data has been received and so on so
forth whereas udp is a connection less
protocol where data is just dumped
without verifying whether the receiver
actually receives that data or not so
in a nutshell on the transport layer tcp
and udp
make their appearance and this is where
that functionality lies
then comes the session there this
controls signals between the computer it
establish maintains and
terminates connections between processes
so in the transport layer we talked
about tcp and udp
udp being a connection less protocol
where data is just
transmitted without verifying whether
the receiver received that data or not
whereas tcp we studied is more of a
reliable protocol
thus there are different packets signals
that will be sent across to verify that
data has been transmitted it has been
received properly
and then the next uh segment of that
data is being sent
so those control signals are established
using the session layer so the three-way
handshake of tcp
the acknowledgement packets and
those kind of packets will be taken
taken care of on the session
layer of the osi model
then comes the presentation layer the
presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right
mime or encoding that is being utilized
the utf-8
character set that we utilize for uh
presentation
encryption mechanisms all of these work
on the presentation layer
and finally comes the application layer
where the application itself uses
a particular protocol so that the
other machine on the receiving end the
application on that machine will be able
to understand
what the communication was about right
so in a nutshell
if if i start from up top the
application layer
will deal with any of the data that the
application
is generating so maybe an user input
you're logging in you're typing the
username password
all that data will be constructed let's
say into an http or https format
that's where application layer comes
into picture then the formatting of
which into utf-8
and the encryption of which would be
done at the presentation layer
then this transport layer and the
session layer would kick in to establish
a tcp session do the three-way handshake
establish that connectivity ip
addressing would be done on the network
layer mac addressing would be done on
the data link layer
and when everything is ready on the
physical layer the packet will be sent
out at the receiving end the packet will
be received on the physical layer and
then all these
layers will be reversed and finally at
the application layer the data would be
presented to the application who would
then execute it and showcase it on the
screen
of the recipient so this is the way you
want to explain this
question you want to be very concise
precise about what you are explaining
you don't want to go into two
hypothetical scenarios
you don't want to delete earlier with
the
layers you just want to give the basic
functionality want to demonstrate that
you understand what the osi layer is
how the computer functions and you want
to move on from there
if the interviewer has any further
follow-up questions they will ask those
specific questions
so that's question one moving on to the
question two
question two is define unicasting
multicasting and broadcasting
now this is a question which can be very
lengthy but again
most of your interview questions are
designed that way
it's basically to understand how much
conceptually you are aware about these
technologies so you have to be very
concise
don't go rattling about technology too
much
but in a concise manner just try to
explain what these things is
so when data is being transmitted over a
network it can be
transmitted either in one of these
particular manners it can either be a
unicast
multicast or a broadcast so what is
unicost
unicast is when a message is sent from a
single user
to a single receiver so one to one
right so one machine talking to
another machine and nobody else so also
known as point-to-point communications
one point to one of the point if you
have to send information to multiple
receivers
then you will have to send it using
multicast
right so this is where your multicast
networking comes into picture so in our
case
uh let's assume it's a network where
there are uh there's a class c network
approximately 255 odd machines
and within these there are two machines
that want to talk to each other
if they want to talk between each other
it would be a point to point
communication where they will utilize
unicast
where only these two machines will have
visibility of that conversation
and the other machines will not even
realize that this conversation is taking
place
if one machine wants to talk to multiple
machines
then the multicast comes into the
picture as the name suggests
in this mode of communication data is
sent from one or more or more
sources to multiple destinations
multicast uses the internet group
management protocol also known as the
igmp protocol
to identify groups so under this igmp
protocol
various groups are created where
machines
are subscribed to those particular
groups and whenever
a message needs to be sent through those
groups it will be identified
by the igmp protocol and then that
particular message will be sent
to those multiple machines that are
members of those particular groups
and then comes the broadcast the third
method is known as the broadcast
as it says it is going to broadcast to
all so this is one to all
that is communication between a single
user and it is going to be sent
to all the machines in that particular
network
right so the three ways unicast is one
two one
multicast is one to many and broadcast
is one to all then question number three
what is dns dns stands for domain name
system it is like the internet's phone
book that is responsible for mapping the
domain name
into its corresponding ip address and
let me give you an example over here
whenever we go and open up let's say a
browser a google chrome browser
we type in www.google.com
and then we press enter and magically
google comes in front of us the website
rather
now how does the computer know who
google is because as far as we are
concerned
humans understand google and words like
that computers don't computers
deal with binary zeros and ones right
and as far as internet is concerned they
will only deal with ip addresses and mac
addresses
so how does a computer know how to find
google.com and where is it located
so the moment we type in in the browser
window in the address bar google.com and
press enter
a dns query is generated automatically
by the browser
where a packet is sent to our dns
servers asking
what the ip address is so in short dns
resolves
domain names to their corresponding ip
addresses
there is a dns server which will have
this index
a database of all the domains associated
with their ip addresses if one
particular dns server does not have that
information that you are looking for
it may query another dns server who may
have that particular response so the
first thing is when you type in
domain name it gets resolved with the
dns
it identifies the ip address
corresponding to that particular domain
name
and thus allows the computer to route
that packet to the particular
server where that domain name resides
so in this scenario if you look at the
screen on the local pc you have typed in
cybersecurity.com
there is a dns resolution that a query
that goes
to the dns server what is the ip of
cybersecurity.com
the dns server looks it up in its
particular database
if it has the corresponding ip address
it will then respond back
the ip addresses 172.17.252.1
after which the packet is sent off to
cybersecurity.com
moving on to question number four what
is a firewall
now this is a very good question and
normally a very basic answer that i've
ever heard is that a firewall is a
hardware and a software firewall
but that's the functionality of a
firewall that is what how you can
install a firewall
but there are different types of
firewalls and there is a specific
functionality that the firewall is
created for
right so firewall is either a hardware
or software
but its responsibility is for blocking
either incoming
or outgoing traffic from the internet to
your computer
they secure a network so essentially the
firewall will allow a connection to
happen or disallow a connection to
happen
it won't go beyond that that's the basic
functionality of a firewall
okay so based on the configurations that
you have done
based on the rules that you have created
on the firewall it will then
based on those rules identify whether
some traffic is allowed
in that network or some traffic is to be
blocked from entering that network
so as the screen shows the firewall
rules will analyze whether the traffic
is good
if yes it will allow if the traffic is
bad it will block the traffic
and not allow that connection from
happening in the first place
now there are few common types of
firewalls that also need to be included
in the answer to this question
and the first one is a packet filtering
firewall these are the most common types
that you will come across
which analyze packets and lets them pass
through only if they match
an established security rule set now
here people do get confused when we say
that we analyze packets
people think that these firewalls will
analyze the contents of that packet
which is not correct when the definition
for a packet filtering firewall says
that these firewalls
analyze packets it means that they are
only analyzing the source
and destination ip addresses port
numbers and the protocols that are
mentioned in those packets
these firewalls do not have the
capability of deep packet inspection
or dpi as it is known if that capability
comes into the picture you're basically
looking at an intrusion detection system
or intrusion prevention system in
today's world called as a next-gen
firewall
okay so a packet filtering firewall
essentially will only analyze data
packets
for its source and destination ip
addresses port numbers
and the protocol that is being utilized
it will then map that information to the
rules that are there
on the firewall and based on those rules
it will either allow that a connection
to happen or disallow that connection
from happening
the second type of is a proxy firewall
these firewalls filter network traffic
at the application level so when you say
application level
they work at the layer 7 of the osi
model
packet filtering firewalls since we have
mentioned that they've worked on ip
addressing and port numbers
will work on the network layer of the
osi model
also on the transport layer because you
also look at protocols
proxy firewalls will work at layer 7
which is the
application layer of the osi model and
will deal with application level
protocol such as http
https ftp smtp and so on so forth
and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall
these filter packets are the network
transport and application layers
so they basically do the job of the
first and the second type of firewalls
the packets are compared to known
trusted packets
but now the first question is if there
is a stateful multi-layer inspection
firewall
why do we have type 1 and type 2
firewalls like packet filtering and
proxy firewalls that is because that is
how the firewalls have evolved
we started off with the packet filtering
then we added functionality to it
and so on so forth so if a question
comes what is a firewall you start off
with the
option saying it is a hardware or
software this is the responsibility the
functionality of a firewall
is to allow good traffic and disallow
bad traffic based on the rules that have
been configured on the firewall
and then you've got basically three
types of firewalls packet filtering
proxy and stateful multi-layer
and just include a brief description of
each of these firewalls
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more then moving on to question
number five
what is a vpn vpn is also called a
virtual private
network it is a connection between a vpn
server and a vpn client
so it basically creates an encrypted
tunnel
between the client and the vpn server
which is then utilized
to secure the connections that you're
making with the
internet so as you can see in the
diagram the user has a vpn client
installed on their machine
the vpn client then creates an encrypted
tunnel to the vpn server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted
which can then be processed by the vpn
server
uh sent to the internet information can
receive can be received back by the vpn
server
the vpn server will encrypt that data
back and send it back to the user
so if there is a man in the middle
attack that is happening or a hacker
trying to eavesdrop on the
communication mechanism they will not be
able to do so because of the encrypted
it is very difficult to decrypt this or
hack through this encrypted tunnel
it is possible but it is very difficult
to achieve that
moving on to question number six what
are the advantages of distributed
processing
now before we go into advantages of
distributed processing we first have to
understand what is distributed
processing
so it is a term which describes various
computer systems
that use more than one processor to run
an application
here multiple computers across different
locations
share the same processor the advantages
of distributing processes
are as follows but before we go into the
advantages distributed computing
is basically where multiple machines
will pull their resources together
to run a singular application so an
application that has
multiple resources and can scale up and
scale down as and when required
the advantages are that it can be very
very useful in data recovery for example
raid
where you're striping data on various
hard disks
it is reliable it is cheaper lower cost
can be achieved
and it is easy to expand because of the
scalability factor that we just
talked about if there is loss of data in
one computer it can then be recovered
by another interconnected computer and
one of the examples would be
blockchain in today's world right what
is blockchain that this data is
uh created live and stored on a
connection of computers so if one of the
computers goes offline
the other computers in that network will
still have that data
and there the blockchain will still
function without any issues
the second point a glitch in one machine
does not affect the processing as there
will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain several cost effective mini
computers are used instead of costly or
mainframe machines so instead of having
a server bank
i can have multiple machines connect
interconnected together
and they can function in that particular
blockchain or for that particular
distributed processing mechanism
on the amount of data processing more
computers can be attached to the network
thus
you can increase the number of computers
that can be a part of that blockchain
or you can reduce them as and when
necessary moving on to question number
seven
what is tcpip tcpip or transmission
control protocol
over internet protocol is a set of
communication protocols that are used to
interconnect networking devices
on the internet this protocol defines
how data should be transmitted over the
internet
by providing end-to-end communications
so essentially if you want networking to
be
established on your machine you will
need tcp
without tcp iep there will be no work
groups there will be no domains
basically your interconnectivity will go
for a toss
tcp is a software that once installed on
your machine
will then interact with the hardware
which is your network interface cards
and then your switches wires cables and
all those through protocols that have
been already
pre-configured in it so within the tcp
iep
suite of softwares you will have all the
protocols
all the functionality of the osi layer
and each and every protocol that works
on each and every layer
will be predefined and pre-configured to
work in a particular manner
the internet protocol is all about
routing each individual packet to make
sure it reaches its destination
so with the tcp you're talking about the
protocols that will allow you to
format the data and generate it so that
you can communicate it over the network
the ip will then deal with the routing
of those packets so that
the packet can be routed to the correct
computer and be received by the
recipient
so the tcp model is the compressed
version of the osi
the seven layers will get converted into
four layers the network access layer
internet layer transport layer and
application layer going on to question
eight
what do you mean by ipconfig and
ifconfig both of these are commands the
first one on a windows machine the
second one on a linux machine
so ipconfig is known as the internet
protocol configuration
this is a command that is used on the
command line interface of microsoft
windows
to view all the adapters and the
configuration of each and every adapters
for their network interfaces so as you
can see on the right hand side in the
command prompt screen
if once you type in the ip config
command on the c prompt
and press enter it will give you a list
of all the adapters that are there
so you can see wireless lan adapter
local area connection the media is
disconnected it doesn't exist
at the bottom you'll see the wi-fi
connection wireless lan adapter
and can give you the ip version 6 ip
address
ip version 4 address the subnet mask and
the default gateway so this is the
configuration that allows the machine
to know on what network it is on what is
the default gateway for communicating to
the
internet what is the subnet mask so how
many computers may
exist in that particular network and
what is the ip address of that specific
computer
so that it can communicate across the
network as well
ifconfig is the same thing on the linux
mac or unix operating system
so the command will also give you the
list of interfaces
and the configuration of each and every
interface it is used to configure
control the tcp network interface
parameters from the command line
interface
it allows you to see the ip address of
these network interfaces so here you can
see
uh the wlp19s
the ip address being 192.168.43.215
subnet mask being 255.255.255.0
with the broadcast being 192.168.43.255.
question nine what is the difference
between a domain and a work group
this can be a very interesting question
and can be a very lengthy question at
the same time
a work group is nothing but a
decentralized network
where you have interconnected multiple
machines together and each machine
acts in its own individual capacity
thinks of itself as a server
right so a decentralized network use
every user manages the resources
individually on their pc
so local users on their own pcs
managing the network shares what can be
shared from that particular machine what
data
should be shared should not be shared to
whom it can be shared with and so on so
forth
it is good if you've got a small network
uh a few machines all together
uh and you want them to interact with
minimal
management effort right so each computer
each user will decide what they want to
allow
other users to see on that particular
network and all of them would be
connected over a lan
a local area network either a wireless
or a wired one so
if you look at your home wi-fi right now
that is one of the best examples
of having a work group the domain on the
other hand is a centralized network
model
so in a corporate environment whenever
you go there and you got a domain based
username and password
which when entered onto a particular
machine gives you access
to the entire network or whatever
applications and whatever resources have
been allocated to you
that is where the domain comes in so it
it also uses a single sign on
mechanism for all the resources that are
that are to be made available to you
whereas in a work group your local user
only meant
for that particular computer right so
coming back to the domain
it is an administrator who is going to
manage the entire domain and all of the
resources connected to the domain
the resources could be switches routers
servers data stores
applications web servers mail exchange
servers and so on so forth so all of
these
are administered by an administrator
through the domain
it is the most reliable and optimum
solution for a large network
where multiple users are going to
interconnect and share that data
amongst each other right the computer
can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a vpn you can connect to your corporate
network authenticate in
and get access to whatever resources you
are allowed to access whereas in a work
group
you have to be a part of that network to
access that internet
if you change your location you go and
connect to another wi-fi
you will lose access to your previous
wi-fi then the last question for the
networking
section what is data encapsulation in
networking data encapsulation refers to
the process of adding headers
and trailers to the data the data link
layer
binds each packet into a frame that
contains the hardware
address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when you're talking about data
encapsulation
we have talked about how data that has
been created by the application layer
would have a header and a trailer that
will give
the various informations of where that
data needs to be sent
so the hardware address which is the mac
address comes into the picture and gets
added to the header
and the ip addresses port numbers and
all of those things
would then be added to this uh trailers
as well so that
the data can be then routed to the
intended recipient of that particular
communication
with this we end the first 10 questions
in networking and in this video we are
going to look at
software and programming so we're going
to look at the first 10 questions
first question being how do you keep a
computer secure
now this is going to be a very generic
question so
you want to put your best foot forward
and you want to
identify the most common methodologies
on how you can keep a computer secure
so when you talk about computers the
first thing that you want to talk about
is authentication mechanisms
where you want multi-factor
authentication or two-way authentication
to ensure
that your accounts are kept secured now
if you look at
using passwords depending on how
passwords are being stored by the
application
uh password attacks can be possible
either a brute force attack or a
dictionary based attack
or even password guessing attacks are
possible to mitigate those kind of
attacks
you will need multi-factor
authentication to ensure that
accounts are kept secure now even if we
are using multi-factor authentication we
also want to look at secure passwords
which means that the password is complex
enough to withstand most of the common
attacks
and a brute force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible
so we want to randomize our passwords we
want to create a complexity where a
password meets
standard such as me has at least
one lowercase one uppercase character
has
numerics and special characters and is
randomized is not based on a dictionary
word
doesn't contain usernames email
addresses phone numbers or anything that
is personal to that particular
user third keep regular updates
which means that there will be patches
that will be released for the
application for the software that you're
utilizing
download the patches install them on a
regular basis to ensure that
you are secured against the most recent
attacks that have been
identified install a good antivirus
could be a internet security suite which
will have an antivirus
intrusion detection system a firewall
and will help you
protect yourself against ransomwares
malwares
and any script-based attacks also have a
specialized
firewall on your system could be a
host-based firewall or a network-based
firewall
to ensure that attacks are kept at a
minimum
and you have your network definitions in
place
to allow or disallow connections from
happening to your devices
have anti-phishing software installed as
well to ensure that
you are not getting any spam mails even
if you do you are able to identify that
and not fall prey or victim to those
spam males phishing attacks are generic
where they are directed towards
individuals
and they prey on the gullibility of that
particular individual so our nigerian
frauds
or the lotteries that we win on a
regular basis of hundreds of million
dollars
those messages the emails that we
receive they are all phishing emails
where
uh they're basically prone to victimize
the
user and then drop them off money or
install some malware or do some other
malicious activity
if you want to enhance encryption about
data that you have stored on your
devices
or on your or that is accessed by your
software or being transmitted by your
software
use encryption encrypt your data whether
it is at rest whether it is in motion or
whether it is at use
thus reducing data leakage and data loss
uh possibilities
and finally in the foremost secure your
dns dns is the domain name server
which is utilized by
computers to resolve domain names to ip
addresses
if a dns poisoning attack is possible
where your dns settings have been
modified by an attacker and you are
redirected to a malicious dns server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application
which may have a malware or a malicious
software
as a payload also you don't want
people to know your dns servers and the
queries that you're making
so you want to use secure dns or dns
over https
to encrypt your dns queries as well
so in a nutshell if you follow these
eight steps
your devices your computers your
applications are going to be as secure
as possible
the next question discuss security
related aspects between c
c plus plus and java now this is an
open-ended question it depends on which
level
you're giving an interview on but you're
looking at it from a fresher's
perspective
or a less experienced perspective and
thus these are some of the aspects that
we want to look at and the comparisons
between c
c plus plus and java so the five aspects
that we are looking at
are pointers code translations storage
allocation
inheritance and overall
security are based on cc plus plus and
java
so when we say pointers we are looking
at
how we are going to uh we are using
pointers and
stacks and heaps to point to functions
and how we exit those functions
and how those functions are then
recalled
into the next function so c supports
pointers it is most secure
c plus plus also supports point pointers
but it is a little bit less secure than
c
java it is not supported turret access
is given to memory allocation
and thus it is the least secure as far
as pointers are concerned
when we look at code translations c
is able to compile but it is not secure
same with cc plus plus
but in java it is interpreted language
and it is abstracted and secured
in storage allocation in c we use malloc
and
uh catalog memory allocation which is
less secure because it does not have
internal checks on
verifying what memory is allocated and
the user input that is being
compiled or that is being input to that
memory
right thus this can allow buffer
overflow errors
uh to creep in because of the uh
non-verification of the input data so it
is the least secure
in cc plus plus it uses new and delete
options and is comparatively secure but
java uses a garbage collector
and thus is the most secure as well as
storage allocation is concerned
when we talk about inheritance the most
secure is ccp plus plus c has no
inheritance so it's not secure
in c plus plus it is supported does
it is the most secure whereas in java
there's multi inheritance that is not
supported
and does is comparatively secure
overall the most secure out of all these
based on these five aspects is java
the least secure is c and the
mid level is c plus plus moving on to
question 13
what are the different sources of
malware now malware stands for malicious
software
right malware is basically a software
that poses as a legitimate software but
has a payload of a trojan virus spyware
keylogger
or some malicious software that is going
to have a negative impact on security
of your particular device so the
question here is what are the different
sources of malware
we want to identify the most common
sources
through which malwares infect end-user
devices in today's world
and you can start with pop-up ads so
most of the websites if you are visiting
untrusted sites if you're being
redirected to sites that you don't know
about
there'll be a lot of pop-ups coming your
way where it says you're the one
millionth
visitor to this site please click here
to download your gift
or it will say congratulations on
winning a particular
product for visiting this page and so on
so forth there are some
instances where you can see a banner
which is flashing at you
on top of the page and says that there
are eight
uh infections that have been identified
on your computer click here to download
an antivirus to clean the infections so
all of these pop-ups
are there as a social engineering attack
as a phishing attack
to make gullible people click on those
links and download those
malwares now the software that is posing
as a security software itself
can be a malicious software which is
going to install a trojan or a virus or
a bot
on your machine compromising the
security of that machine
the second is removable media usbs and
humans have a fascination with usb
so if you find a usb lying around
it's a free usb you get excited about it
and you want to
take it home you want to plug it into a
machine and see what's on the usb
worst case scenario you format it and
you've got a free usb to utilize
higher the capacity the better but that
is one of the most
easiest way people use malware
to uh to be deployed on unsuspecting
users
if there is a usb lying around why would
why would somebody want to forget a usb
it's most likely
planted over there as a social
engineering attack so that a gullible
person is going to pick it up
plug it into their device if the device
is not secured enough
it is going to install the malware right
uh then documents and executable files
this is where your viruses
and uh all those creeps in so let's say
you're surfing on the internet you're
looking for a software
uh and you find the software on a
particular website
you do not verify the trustworthiness of
that site
and you just download and install that
software now that software could be
malware as well thus if you're surfing
on the internet you're downloading files
from different locations you have to
research the website you have to
research the source
to ensure that it is trustworthy and
only then are you going to download and
execute those files
thus internet downloads as well and when
we say internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrents uh
we go to
uh the dark web or the deep web and
we're searching for other softwares
especially uh those who are researching
security right
we always want we are always on the
lookout of new softwares
and we are always on those forums which
may not be so much
trustworthy and we just download those
files and start installing them
that is a very bad scenario right so you
have to be very careful what you're
downloading from the internet
your antiviruses your uh anti-fishing uh
mechanisms
your threat intelligence mechanisms uh
have those
uh mechanisms installed and you want to
verify where your downloads are coming
from then your network connections if it
is a p2p connection it is a local area
network connection or a metropolitan
area network you have to verify
whom which devices are connected to your
machines
and you have to validate those
connections before you want to trust
those devices
uh and before you connect to them if
you're on a public wi-fi
you probably don't want to connect to a
public wi-fi in the first place
then comes email attachments
there are so many attachments that come
across in today's world most of them in
a zip format or a rar format
uh some of them come as document files
where there are macros hidden within
them macros are scripts that are
recognized by microsoft office files
right and then finally there are these
malicious advertisements that we
find online right uh let it be facebook
let it be whatsapp let it be
uh any social media platform that you go
or even your search engines their job is
to display ads
their job is not to verify whether the
ad is legit or not
it is for us as consumers to be careful
and validate that ad and verify whether
it is a genuine ad or not
so just don't start clicking on uh any
of the ad trusting
uh the platform that you're on be
uh be sure that you are investigating
that so these are the most
common sources of malware and
the end user will always get infected by
one of these mechanisms
moving on to question 14
how does email work now this is a very
uh
can be a complex question uh but we have
to keep it as simple as possible
and we have to identify that there are
uh two servers
while uh both of them either using smtp
which is the simple message transfer
protocol
where in this scenario john
wants to send an email thus they've got
an email client installed on their
machine
which is connected to the mail exchange
server which has a dns server which
maps the routing and which maps the
exchange server and inboxes so when john
composes that message and clicks on send
john should be connected to a mail
exchange server
where the email is sent through that
particular person's inbox
so john's inbox will then uh
be validated and that email will then be
sent through the dns server
uh through the internet and will be
received by the
recipient mail server so at this point
in time john also requires
the recipient's email address so in this
case this is jack
so jack at something.com would be the
email address
so while john is composing the two field
will have jack's email address
the from field will have john's email
address the subject field will have
whatever they want to convey as a
message the message body will have the
message itself
and then when john clicks on send it
will go to
direction server the exchange server
will then validate the
inbox and identify where that inbox is
located
for jack and then through the internet
it will be sent
to the uh to the mail server of jack the
mail server will then identify the
proper
inbox that it now that that email is to
be sent to and it will store that email
in that particular inbox
when jack opens their computer and
accesses their inbox
this email from john will be already
waiting for them
and they can respond to it the same way
john had sent that email
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more moving on to question 15
what are the types of threats a company
can face
right and this is where your threat
modeling comes into the picture so
you're looking at software you're
looking at operating systems
and the company comes and asks you what
are the threats that are most likely
that a company will face so on a broader
scale the threats that a company will
always face
would be classified as natural threats
man-made threats
technical threats and a supply system
threat
so a natural threat would be an act of
god which is outside the control of
human beings
could be storms or any natural
occurrences like
volcanoes thunderstorms flooding
earthquakes fire and so on so forth so
anything that is natural so it depends
on the geographic location that you're
in
and what kind of climate that area faces
and you need to
identify the immediate threats and
prepare for them so if it is
flooding that you're looking at and you
want to look at an office
uh and the possibility of the office
getting flooded is
real you probably want to take office at
a higher floor
so that the threat of flooding is
minimized
for fire we always have a fire drill
where we practice our fire mechanism so
that we can evacuate all humans as soon
as possible
and then worry about the technicalities
of it
under any circumstances under any
threats humans will always have the
first priority
and then everything else comes in
manmade threats are
where man themselves are a problem so
strikes lockouts
hackers theft war
writing all of those are man-made
threats
which we ourselves cannot be in control
of
but we need to plan for them and we need
to have
a business continuity plan or a disaster
if you plan for any of these threats
that have been identified
then come the technical threats
technical could be software bugs
operating system bugs application bugs
that
uh that come with the applications that
we have or a hardware failure where a
server crashes
a hard disk crashes maybe
the processor stops working the
motherboard stops working
ram gets corrupted any of the technical
aspects
a stopping uh stop functioning does
creating a break in the business can
come under technical
right so uh anything to do with
computers
let's say a server failing or a
patch that is not installed on the
particular software those would come
under technical
threats and then the supply system the
supply system are your environmental
threats
which require depend on your supply
chain failures
what is the supply chain for office to
function there are a lot of
dependencies that office goes through
right there are a lot of other vendors
that suppose
that support and provide critical
infrastructure non-critical
infrastructure for the office to
function
for first and foremost electricity
without electricity nothing is going to
be powered on
and you're not going to be able to
function so if there is an electricity
service provider
and if there is an electric outage
that's that comes under supply system
so that's a supply chain failure where
the
vendor that provides electricity to you
has failed in providing that particular
service
and now you need a business continuity
or a disaster recovery plan
so you probably have an inverter or you
already have a
power generator plant that is going to
generate your own power and supply to
your system
right they could be short circuits
because of fluctuation in the
electricity
uh maybe the internet service provider
fails and your internet caches so you
have a backup line for the internet from
a different vendor
right and so on so forth maybe your
hardware vendors who are supplying you
servers desktops laptops and whatnot
they fail because they feel they are
facing a strike or they go bankrupt
and suddenly you can no longer purchase
hardware
from your vendor because they no longer
are in business so that's a supply chain
failure
so any of these systems failing would
also come under threats
so under a broad category these are the
first four threads that you need to
identify and then you can
elaborate by providing more scenarios
based on the experiences that you have
had
towards each and every of these threats
so natural threat where you may have had
experience
where there would have been let's say
flooding uh or
any natural disaster which caused a
problem for the
continuity of your particular business
so identify each and every
example for each of these threats and
provide that as an example
in the interview what is black box and
white box testing
so when you are testing a software or
you are testing your infrastructure
there are two different tests that you
can conduct the first one is a black box
the second one is a white box
in a black box test there is no
knowledge that is shared with the tester
so
let's say you're an ethical hacker and
you have been awarded a contract by an
organization
to test the current application that
they have developed
now they are not going to give you any
information they are not going to tell
you what the application is they just
probably give you an ip address and a
port number where the application is
hosted
and now you have to fire in your own
queries and try to figure out
what the application is try to gather
information
see what uh what information can be
gathered in the first place
and based on that you're going to figure
out your way identify vulnerabilities
and see if any of those vulnerabilities
can lead to an security incident
so without any knowledge zero knowledge
of the id infrastructure or the source
code
that's a black box attack or a black box
test
a white box test on the other hand is
where full knowledge of the id
infrastructure or the source code is
shared
so the ethical hacker has complete
knowledge
and based on the knowledge they are then
going to test out the system to see if
there are any flaws that they can
identify
right so why would these two audits be
important
because the first one a black box audit
emulates
the attack of a outsider a external
hacker sitting
outside the organization trying to
figure their way in whereas a white box
attack
can emulate the attack of an insider so
a disgruntled employee within that
organization
misusing their access controls or the
access rights
to make uh unvalidated profits
right so somebody is corrupt who has
been bribed
who wants to sell out company secrets
based uh so they're going to try to find
out vulnerabilities
try to steal data and try to sell it on
the uh
gray market right so a white box would
emulate a
internal attack a black box would
emulate an external attack
moving on to question 17 what is use
case testing
now use case testing is a functional
test
and it is also a black box test right
what is a functional test
it tests the functionality of a
particular software once it has been
created
why is it a black box test because the
user doesn't know what the functionality
is they just want to find out each and
every scenario
and try to see what that scenario
generates as a response
they are not sure whether that is the
appropriate response that should be
generated or not
they're just trying to find out the
response that is going to be generated
after they fire off a query so this
technique is used by testers
to get the test scenarios to exercise
the whole system from start to finish
so let's say it's a login mechanism for
an application
right now a user at this point in time
the tester since it's a black box
testing
will know that it is a login mechanism
they will not know the details of what
logging mechanisms are being utilized so
they wouldn't know whether uh input
validation is done
they wouldn't know whether output
encoding is done they wouldn't know how
the cgi calls are being made
they will not know how the queries are
handled at the server side
and how the database is going to treat
that particular query
so they have no idea whether the sql
injection attacks are possible and so on
so forth
so for them with whatever input they are
going to try to insert
for that login mechanism that's a
functional black box test
the functionality being whether the
login mechanism works
and based on the type of inputs that are
going to put in
whether it creates an unwarranted output
whether they can bypass the mechanism or
they can
hack into the system because of some of
the flaws that were left behind
right another example here is a software
made for users to use for documentation
the testers will test all the cases that
the user can do so can the user
view a document can they add new
documents can they edit documents and
can they delete documents
so this functionality will depend upon
the access controls that have been
granted to a particular user so for this
particular user the tester at this point
in time
they would not know whether they're an
administrative user or they're a regular
user
they'll just try to do all of these and
then write the responses saying
i was able to view i was able to add i
was able to edit and i was able to
delete
now the result will be then sent to a
manager the manager will look at the
results
and then based on the actual access
controls that were supposed to be there
for this particular user then we'll try
to identify whether this is an
acceptable case
or whether there were any flaws within
this case
moving on to question 18 what is static
and dynamic testing now this is again in
application testing
static testing is done in an early stage
of development life cycle now
software development life cycles there
are multiple of those what are these
life cycles
there are different stages in which a
application is
created and provided to the customer
so your first stage would be determining
the scope of the application
determining the hardware requirements
for that application then
creating a flowchart for that
application a functional chart for that
application
and then maybe start coding then an
architect comes in tests the code
verifies the code then the testing phase
comes in then the security testing phase
comes in
and then the user acceptance testing
comes in but
in every stage at the very earliest of
first stage a static test will always be
started
to see whatever code has been developed
whatever uh
scope has been developed whether that
scope is going to be correct or not
this will include walkthroughs and code
review what is a walkthrough
a walkthrough is going through documents
that have been generated
and trying to find faults in the
documented journey that has been talk
that has been created so far so let's
say somebody has created a workflow
or a flowchart for a program how the
functions are going to be called and how
they're going to be executed
so a walkthrough would be where uh all
these
responsible people will walk through
that particular flowchart and find out
any flaws within that
and then rectify them if there is any
code that has already been written
this code will be reviewed manually and
any flaws within that code would then be
identified
static testing will always be 100
accurate in a very short amount of time
because it is immediate
uh you have created it and then the
expert is going to test it to see
whether everything is fine or not
right it is all about prevention
mechanism so since you are doing it at
the inception itself
if you find any flaw it gets immediately
repaired so this is about preventing
vulnerabilities from keeping into that
application at a later point in time
whereas dynamic on the other side is
done at the end of the development
lifecycle so you have generated the
application
everything is ready now you want to do
dynamic testing
includes functional and non-functional
testing functional testing is where
the application itself is being tested
the functions to see that all the
parameters that are given to the
application are functioning properly
non-functional testing would be where
security parameters
uh administrative parameters all of them
are being verified
right this is where your test case
scenarios come in
and you're going to test each and every
scenario
by generating inputs and analyzing the
output that the application is going to
give you
dynamic testing is all about cure so
here you're going to identify
vulnerabilities
report them to the management and the
management is then going to figure out a
way
of patching those vulnerabilities so
that they can be mitigated
moving on to the next question what are
the test levels in software testing
so as far as software testing is
concerned there are four test levels
module testing integration testing
system testing
and the final one is acceptance testing
so in the testing phase of your
development life cycle
the first thing is a module test you're
going to check
your routines your subroutines your
subprograms procedures that have been
written in a program
so all your functions all your
mechanisms
for that application are going to be
tested when you go into integration
testing
the software may have been integrated
with multiple softwares there may be
different api calls coming in
maybe a third party software on which
you are depending upon to supply for
information
so all of these integration of various
software's various apis
are tested to ensure that they are
functioning properly
and there are no flaws errors or
mistakes left behind
in the integration of all of these
softwares
then the system testing is where the
entire system so
including the hardware including the
software right it starts from the
installation
so now the software is complete we know
which hardware we are going to support
for it
we start by installing the software and
see whether the installation is going to
be completed properly
if there are any errors in the
installation process itself
then once it is installed the
performance of that particular
application
the write speeds the read speeds on the
hard disk
the transaction speeds that the
application is capable of
the network dependencies that the
application may have all of those would
come under system testing
and then the acceptance testing which is
basically a
quality assurance exercise that
the application meets the client's
requirements
so the client in the first stage would
have given the scope of what needs to be
achieved
in the acceptance testing you're
verifying that that scope has been met
and the client requirements uh have been
met and you can assure the client
about the functionality and the
performance of that particular
application
coming to the last question in this
software programs what are the valuable
steps to resolve
issues while testing so in the previous
scenarios when we have started testing
now if you find out when you execute a
particular use case
and then you find out of law what would
be the
steps that you would utilize to address
those
particular flaws in those tests the
first step will always be record
then you're going to report it and then
you're going to introduce a control
process for it so when you say record
you're going to create logs
and you're going to try to resolve all
the problems that have happened now when
you say resolve
you're not going to record the
application but you're going to test the
system again and again to ensure that
whatever is being recorded is accurate
and all the logs all the error
mechanisms all the
dumps all of those that have been
generated due to this particular log
about due to this particular
error are being captured so that they
can be reported
to the higher level managers so the next
step is once you have
eventually accumulated all these logs
and records you're going to report them
to the higher level managers
who are then going to investigate it and
go back to the developers
trying to figure out the best way to
mitigate those particular
flaws so the report writing needs also
also needs to be accurate
uh it needs to be to the point uh it
needs to detail what the problem was it
will
document all the steps that they were
that you took all the
inputs that you put in and it will also
record
all the errors and it will also record
all the mechanisms that were utilized
and the
errors that were regenerated and that
report will be given to the higher level
managers who can then forward it to the
developers
who based on those reports can draw
start their troubleshooting
and then the control mechanism comes in
you're going to
define the issue management process so
this process needs to work in a
particular manner where you're
doing a test you're recording whatever
is happening you're creating a report
out of it you're sending it to the
management
the management will then take those
reports study them
take it to the developers the developers
will test based on
their criterias they might interact with
the testers at that point in time to
identify particular flaws and then they
might want to record that application on
a developer patch
which once installed will mitigate that
particular flaw
and then it can come back to the testing
phase again where you can repeat those
tests
and validate that the flaw is no longer
existing
so these are the three steps that would
be utilized
for testing purposes and that brings us
to the first 10
questions on the software platform in
the next video we'll be looking at
operating systems and applications
the first question is on virtual memory
what exactly is virtual memory
for a computer we have two types of
memory the first is the primary memory
which is your random access memory
which is also known as a volatile memory
and the secondary memory is your hard
disk where your data is stored
permanently
but for a computer when it has let's say
a 4gb memory or a ram
as in this scenario on your screen it is
going to replicate that
and is going to create another 4 gb of
virtual memory on the hard disk
and it is going to use it in tandem
along with the ram
so if the ram is insufficient the
processor is going to utilize
the 4gb of the virtual memory that is
created on the hard disk
and it is going to swap data from the
ram to the hard disk
this can also be known as a page file or
a swap file
the next question is what are different
scheduling algorithms
now the context for this question is
you're talking about a profi
processor and you're talking about how
processes are going to be fed to the
processor and how the process is going
to treat these processes
so the first is first come first serve
so the process which requests the cpu
first
gets the cpu allocation first now
whenever there are processes that are
being run by different applications
they make requests for some cpu time now
in first
come first serve the first service or
the first process that is going to
request
some processing time will get that much
allocated to them
they will run through the process first
and the next and the next and so on so
forth
the second one is the shortest job first
this is the process where the shortest
execution time for that process is
calculated
and that process is selected first for
the cpu
then there is priority scheduling this
scheduler selects the task to work as
per priority
so there would be some tasks that are
marked with high priority some would be
normal
and some would be low so based on this
high
normal or low priority uh all the
processes will be classified higher
priority will be dealt with
first then the normal and the least
priority
the fourth option is multiple level
queues where processors are assigned to
a queue based on the specific property
like process priority the size of memory
etc so it will be classified based on
the
attributes given to that particular
process and
multiple cues will be created and then
based on the attributes the processes
will be
processed by the cpu then
shortest remaining time the process will
be allocated to the task which is
closest to its completion
so or look at it this way the process
that will
take the least time to complete its
processing
would be chosen first and then the round
robin method
where each process comes in turn gets an
equal share of time
so if there are 10 processors each
process will be
allocated a certain amount of time after
which the next process will be processed
and so on so forth
and it will continue in a round robin
fashion
till all the processes get executed
so in short six different scheduling
algorithms
depending on how you how the operating
system deals with it
the next question is what are the steps
involved in hacking a server or a
network so this is more of an ethical
hacking question
you're looking at devices and for and
the interviewer asks you
uh what kind of steps are involved what
are the activities that you would do
in hacking a server or a network now
there are no specific steps that you
would
define because every hack is going to be
unique
but it has a hack can be classified in
five different steps
which are quite generic right so the
first step will always
always be the recognizance step also
known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting
uh depending on what exactly you're
doing but in this phase
the attacker gathers all the evidence
all the information that is possible
about the targets
that they want to attack so here you're
trying to get to know the victim so you
can launch specific attacks
towards them you want to identify what
operating system they are utilizing what
ip addresses mac addresses
the versions of the operating systems
and applications the patch levels
find out vulnerabilities find out
whatever information is possible
find out the information about the uh
person who is using those computers
so you can launch social engineering
attacks and so on so forth so
the first step is all about gathering
enough information
based on which you can launch further
attacks once you have that information
comes the second phase which is known as
the scanning phase
this is more of a technical phase so
yeah right in the first step you've got
your ip addresses domain names
maybe even network maps and you have
identified
which devices are available now in the
scanning phase you're going to identify
live devices and then you're going to
scan them for
open ports processors protocols services
you're going to identify vulnerabilities
you're going to enumerate them to
identify more information from them
thus at this point in time you will have
identified a certain set of
vulnerabilities
or a certain set of security loopholes
that you can misuse once you have
identified those
you're going to the next step which is
the gaining access state
in this you're actually going to execute
your attacks based on the
vulnerabilities that you have found
and you're either going to gain access
to that particular system by installing
a trojan
or destroy the system by installing a
virus or install a spyware or a
keylogger
whatever you wanted to achieve so in the
gaming access phase
you would have based on the knowledge
that you've gained in the first and the
second phase you're going to launch your
attacks and you're going to try to gain
access
to that particular device then the next
step is where you're going to maintain
that access
now that you have hacked into that
device it is not necessary
that you will always be able to get
access to that device
uh suppose you have cracked the password
of that particular user and the user
changes that password
after a few days your attack is
worthless so what you're going to do
here is you're going to maintain your
access
so this is where it is assumed that you
want repeated access to that device and
thus you're going to install a keylogger
or a trojan or some mechanism which will
still allow you to get access to that
device
without the knowledge or the
authorization of that particular user
and finally the last step is where
you're going to cover your tracks
so whatever activity that you have done
so far will
have created logs and will have created
information based on which the victim
will come to know that they have been
compromised and may be able to trace
that activity back to you
so to prevent the user or the victim
from realizing that they have been
hacked
and to prevent them to discover who has
hacked them
you want to cover your tracks by
deleting logs and any references that
point to that particular activity
you're going to hide the files that you
have created so you have installed a
trojan or a key logger
these will create files and directories
you're going to hide them so that they
are not discovered
you're going to hide processes that have
been created you're going to try to
hide all the activity that you have done
so that to conceal
the actual attack and preventing the
user from realizing that they haven't
compromised
so these are the five steps that will be
involved in hacking a server network
application
or any computing device you'll come
across the next question
refers to what are the various sniffing
tools now this is a network-based attack
where you're trying to capture
uh data packages that that are being
transmitted over the network and then
you're going to analyze them
to see if you can capture any sensitive
information like usernames passwords
bank details or any anything of that
sort
now these tools will also depend on
which operating system you're utilizing
for example msn sniffer would work on
microsoft uh
operating systems eater cap would be
based on linux and so on so forth so on
the screen you'll see six different
sniffing tools that work on different
operating systems
wireshark is uh something that is common
both on windows and linux
it is used to analyze network in detail
it is the de facto tool that you will
come across
in most of your ethical hacking
trainings in most
of your organizations when they want to
do data captures
now data capturing or packet capturing
is not only done by hackers to gather
more information but it is also a
known troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and
network administrators to analyze any
issues that may be going on in the
network
right so while the first tool you see on
the screen is wireshark
like we stated is available for windows
linux
as well then there is tcp dump which
again has the same capability of
wireshark but
is a command line version whereas
wireshark also has a gui a graphical
user interface
tcp dump is available on linux
msn sniffer it's a very old tool uh
when we had msn messengers msn messenger
is no longer there
but microsoft does or did have a
microsoft message analyzer tool
uh which they have stopped development
since 2015
but that's another tool that is specific
for microsoft operating systems from
microsoft
that can be installed together more
information then you've got eater cap
which is a tool to launch
man-in-the-middle attacks
data capturing and is is essentially a
linux command line based
tool then d sniff is another password
and
network capturing tool which can help
you capture data packets
prominently a linux tool
same with iterate this is a graphical
tool which will allow you to capture
data
data traffic and map protocols and
identify which ip addresses have been
communicating with what
essentially all of the tools have
similar functionality
except that uh some have additional
functionality like
launching management attacks or
capturing
or having specific filters that will
help you identify and troubleshoot some
network issues that you may be facing
moving on to the next question what is
an operating system
now this is a very difficult question to
answer because
we normally when we want to answer this
question we start off with the
functionality of an operating system
right
we try to describe what windows does or
what linux does or what mac os does
and then we are trying to figure out
what an operating system is in the first
place
but an operating system essentially as
the slide says is a software program
that provides a platform
for computer hardware to communicate and
operate with the computer software
so it is basically an enabler for human
interaction
with the hardware that you have if you
take the operating system
out of the question it's just some
hardware
which cannot interact with you but
essentially when you have operating
system like microsoft windows or linux
or mac
you're essentially essentially
installing an instruction set
on that particular device which will
allow you to interact
and manipulate the hardware to do
whatever you want that hardware to do
right essentially when we talk about
drivers for your various devices like a
driver for your lan card or for your
sound card or your graphics card
which allows you to tweak these cards
for
a functionality right it allows us input
and output functions uh for example the
basic example you open up microsoft
office products like microsoft word or
excel
and you get a gui on the screen uh which
you can interact with you've got a
keyboard and you type on that keyboard
and the computer knows what you're
typing
and reflects those actions on the screen
by showcasing it on that particular
excel file or a word file so how does
the computer know what to do or what
you're exactly
intending to do at this point in time it
is all the operating system
that is providing you all these services
analyzing what your inputs
are and then based on the programming
it is going to execute that and show it
to you on the screen
right some of the most common commonly
used operating system are microsoft
windows
you have them in desktop as well as
server variants
unix linux again linux as desktop
and servers you got ubuntu and linux red
hat
and so on so forth and then you've got
mac os
for apple related components the next
question
what is the difference between micro
kernel and macro kernel now the first
thing we need to know is what is the
kernel
kernel is the
heart of the operating system that
allows that input and output to happen
it allows those drivers to be
set up so that the hardware can interact
with the software
and we can then instruct the software
and the hardware both
to function in a particular manner so
there are two types of kernels micro
kernels and a macro kernel
micro kernel is something that we
normally use micro kernels are for
operating systems that use processors
directly handled by the processor
the micro kernel is very small in size
micro kernel is large because it
basically is the entire image of the
operating system
the execution for a micro kernel is slow
the micro kernel is going to be faster
because it is more evolved there's a lot
of programming involved
extendability microkernels are easy to
extend micro um
micro kernels are hard to extend as far
as security is concerned if a micro
kernel crashes it takes everything down
with it the entire
operating system is going to crash but
in case of a micro kernel
it is only that particular process that
is going to get affected
micro kernel there is a lot of coding
involved
micro kernel less coding is involved
examples of micro kernels would be
simply an oss
most popularly used on yesteryear phones
nokias if you remember those
uh qnx and so on so forth micro kernels
your linux or bsd operating systems
essentially use macro kernels
next question what are the different
types of operating systems
so as you can see on the screen five
types of operating systems
batched os distributed operating systems
time sharing multi-program
and real-time what are batched operating
systems the computer operator places the
jobs coming from input devices into
batches
so consider this not from a desktop
perspective but from a
server perspective where these devices
are used by
organizations to compute and to crunch
some processes that is going to make
some business sense out of it
so when there are multiple processes
coming in multiple jobs that are
going to be scheduled a batched os is
going to place these jobs
in batches and they're going to crunch
those based on the
inputs that have been given by these
operators distributed os is where there
are multiple computers
which are interconnected and are
communicating through networks
so in a corporate environment you don't
use one single computer to do everything
you got a data center
and the data center will have a cluster
of servers where they are going to share
some resources
to crunch one particular task right so
that's where your distributed oss come
into the picture then you have time
sharing oss
where you are renting some time so time
sharing voices minimizes the response
time
example in today's world cloud right
uh you go on to the cloud you have a
virtual service over there
you scheduled something you showed you
the job over there it is
uh it is executed and for that time
being
that operating system services your
particular request
and provides you that particular job
any application that you see online that
is executed for example
facebook from a consumer's perspective
could be a time shared experience then
multi-programmed os the operating system
uses cpu scheduling
to separate jobs so you're scheduling
the cpu to
complete certain jobs in this particular
manner
and in real time os the operating system
gives maximum time to critical
operations so it identifies the priority
of these operations it knows
the high priority items the medium low
priority items and based on that
it is going to execute these critical
operations and get the job done
moving on to the next question what is
the difference between logical address
space
and physical address space now when
you're looking at address spaces
this is where applications come into the
picture and when you execute an
application
it is going to create a particular
address in the memory
where it is going to create a buffer to
store its own information so that it can
be
provided to the processor processed and
then can be returned back to the
application as an output
right so as far as definitions are
concerned a logical address
is generated during running of an
application or a program
a physical address is a physical address
or a physical location on the memory
module itself
right visibility you can view a logical
address
because it is programmed into a computer
so if i'm looking at
cc plus plus and i'm using malloc or
memory allocation
uh that's where the logical address is
going to be created where a buffer is
going to be created for that program
and whatever the user input is going to
be it's going to be stored in that
buffer
but whereas physical addresses are
concerned this logical address
will be created on a physical store or a
physical
memory module which will have its own
addressing mechanism
thus you you can see the memory module
but you cannot see the specific address
on that particular memory module
but as far as a logical address is
concerned by your programming or your
debugging
the application it will show you the
logical address that has been created
the start point and the end point of the
logical address that has been created
for that particular program
and it can be shown in a debugging
environment
right address space logical and
physical addresses physical like i just
guess it's the memory module itself
you can access only the physical address
on that particular memory because
logical addresses can be viewed but you
cannot access them
physically generation uh the logical
addresses are generated by the cpu
uh during the processing time whereas
physical addresses are generated are
computed by the memory management unit
or the mmu that you have on your
computers
and as far as logical addresses they
will always be they are variable
whereas the physical address is always
going to be constant looking at the next
question
what is the difference between logical
address space and physical active space
so moving on from the previous question
to this
the logical address is a address created
by the cpu
for the processors that need to be
addressed and that can be stored as a
buffer
in the physical memory whereas the
physical memory itself
is going to be a address that is going
to be there on the physical part of that
memory
which is uh which is going to be
assigned to it by the
mmu then the next question discusses
uh shells so what shells are used in
linux now what is the shell
shell is the command line interface that
we utilize on a linux machine so
the terminal window as we call it is a
shell
and there are different variations of a
shell based on what linux operating
systems you're using
the desktop operating systems that you
use
or the server operating systems and real
in today's world that you're going to
use
normally we'll always have a bash shell
which is the first shell that you see on
the screen
known as a bone again shell it is a
default for linux distribution
so as far as end consumers regular
consumers are concerned
it is always going to be a bash shell a
bone again shell that you're going to
utilize for scripting and
to execute regular commands but when it
comes to high level programming
or it comes to specialization tasks then
you've got the rest of these
shells that you can utilize for example
the ksh
known as a con shell is used for high
level programming
which supports associative arrays and
built-in operations the csh
or the c shell uh has different
functionality like spelling corrections
and job controls
the zsh or the z-shell provides unique
features like file generation
startup files and fish friendly
interactive shell which provides
features like auto suggestions and
configuration so all of these have
different functionalities
depending on what uh usage that you have
for that particular shell
the most common shell like i stated is
the bash shell that you'll always come
across in your desktop linux operating
systems
then looking at the next question what
are the process states in linux
now what is a process process is
basically a service that is running
for a particular application for that
application to function
right uh this process is going to direct
user input
to the processor process it get that
output back to the application
execute it and then show it onto the
graphical user interface
for the user so in linux there are five
states
for a process first is the ready space
now in ready
in this state the process is created and
it is ready to run so it is waiting
uh it is waiting for input it's ready uh
the application is executed
the running is when the process is being
executed itself
blocked or wait is when user input is
being looked upon
so it's waiting for user input so that
it can do the processing
completed or terminated it has completed
its execution
or was terminated by the operating
system for some reason or the other
so this is where things have uh the
processing has been completed
and then lasted state is zombie where
the process is terminated
but the process table still holds the
information uh maybe it is waiting for
the kill request before it gets
terminated
so these are the five states for a linux
process
to be in and that brings us to the 10
questions in the operating system and
application space
in the next video we'll be looking at 10
more questions on cyber attacks
interview questions based on cyber
attacks
let's start off with the first one the
first question is what is sql injection
sql stands for structured query language
which is a language that is used by most
of your databases
or your relational databases
the variations of your database would be
mysql microsoft sql
oracle sql you'll have ibm databases all
of these databases utilize the
structured query languages
to interact with the applications now
all of these
databases have their own syntax so we'll
have to study
most of these databases based on which
applications and which databases you
want to
provide security for but as the name
suggests
sql injection vulnerability or
structured query language injection
vulnerability
is where a user can maliciously inject
a sql input or a sql statement
in a query and send it to the database
and evoke a response response out of it
so this vulnerability is not
specifically to the database
it uh the vulnerability lies more in the
application and the coding of that
application
so when the application receives a query
which it needs to be forwarded to the
sql
database we need to configure and the
application level
of what queries are allowed and what
queries are not allowed so there are
different various
aspects of how to manage a sql injection
vulnerability
but the basic flaw lies in the
application where
invalidated input is accepted and sent
forward
to the database where the database might
confuse it
into an executable statement and thus
create
a response that was not warranted
there are various types of sequel
injections uh as shown on the screen
in band circular injection where you can
look at an error based or a union based
injection
a blind sql injection where it is either
boolean based or a time-based attack
and then an out-of-bound sql injection
essentially
you're looking at databases and you're
looking at application security
where you want to encourage secure
coding practices so
in unvalidated input is mitigated
the next question is what is spoofing
now in spoofing
you're basically assuming the identity
of another person
so here the attacker pretends to be some
other person or an organization and
sends you an
email that appears to be a legitimate
email
it looks almost genuine it has been
constructed to replicate
what a genuine email would have been and
it is very difficult to spot
a fake one there are different ways to
identify whether an email is genuine or
not
but that's for a different video moving
on to the next question
what is a distributed denial of service
attack
or a ddos attack now generally a denial
of service attack is an attack
where legitimate users are prevented
access to the resources that
they legitimately can access right so
for example if it is
a bandwidth-based attack the attacker
consumes the bandwidth of the network in
such a way
that there is no more bandwidth left for
legitimate users
to access the network now a single
device may not be able to generate that
much amount of
traffic to consume the bandwidth of a
huge server
thus the attacker will construct a
botnet
and through that botnet they will launch
a distributed denial of service attack
to the target victim right so a botnet
there are two uh terms that you want to
look at over here the first
term is a bot and the second one being
the botnet itself
bot is a software that once installed on
a victim's machine
allows the hacker to send remote
commands to that machine
that will make it to generate some
activity
once we have enough machines on which
such
bots have been implemented the
collection of these machines
would be known as a botnet so an
attacker would then instruct this entire
botnet
to start generating data traffic to be
to be sent to the targeted network or to
the targeted server
which will then bog down the server thus
crashing it and preventing
users from accessing that particular
resource
the next question is how to avoid our
poisoning
or arp now first let's understand what
arp is
arp stands for address resolution
protocol which is a protocol used by
computers to communicate over the
network
once your computer boots up it starts a
discovery process
of identifying its neighbors so if i'm
in a particular subnet
my machine will proactively send out a
arb request an address resolution
protocol
to find out which other machines are
within the same network
and which are live once it sends out a
query a live machine will respond to
that query along
with its mac address
this information is then stored in what
is known as a arp
table or an arp table on the machine's
cache so whenever my machine now wants
to send out a packet to this particular
machine it will go to the arp table it
will identify the ip address
and the associated mac address it will
print that onto the data packet
as a destination iep and destination mac
and send that packet across the switch
the switch will then identify the mac
address
and send the packet to the relevant
machine that is
connected to that particular switch now
to confuse the switch
into sending it to a different machine
our poisoning attack is
created this attack is generally
launched to create a man in the middle
attack
now to prevent this arm poisoning from
happening in the first place
there are three different aspects that
we can utilize
first we can use packet filtering which
will
filter out and block packets that are
the same source address data so you have
identified some malicious ip addresses
and you want to block out some ip
addresses so you're using a packet
filter firewall
where you have constructed the firewall
to filter out certain packets
originating from particular range of ip
addresses
this firewall and this technique will
then block those kind of packets coming
in
second keeping away from trust
relationships
organizations will develop protocols
that do not depend on trust
relationships
and thus you want to keep this protocol
away from that
once you have created a trust
relationship uh these machines should
not be
sending out arp requests to other
machines in the first place since
uh the translation has been has been
defined and these machines know whom to
communicate with
such kind of protocols should then be
disabled
or you can use arp spoofing software so
there are some
there are software's out there that will
look for arp spoofing
and prevent that from happening in the
first place so if somebody has sent out
a spoofed arp packet
that packet will be picked up by this
software and
it will be mitigated of network
visualizers like
glass wire antiviruses like so force
uh they haven't built capabilities of
identifying uh
our up spoofing attacks and mitigate
them in the first place
in the next question we are going to
discuss what is ransomware
now ransomware is a type of malware that
blocks victims to access personal files
and demands ransom to
regain access there are three categories
before we go into the categories
let's just revisit what ransomware is
let's start with the word malware
malware is a malicious software
that poses as a legitimate software but
has a payload
that will have a security impact on your
machine
so in this instance viruses trojans
all of these can be classified under
malware so can ransomware
a trojan is a software that will give
you a backdoor access to it
to a particular device a virus will do
some destructive activity on that device
or ransomware will basically encrypt the
data
of that particular user from on that
particular machine
thus rendering that my that data
inaccessible to the users themselves
and in turn will demand the ransom to
provide access
to that particular data so the three
types of ransomwares
the first one is scareware which uses
social engineering to cause an
anxiety or the perception of a threat to
manipulate users into buying unwanted
software
so this preys on the gullibility of
humans where
you can see a pop-up appearing on your
screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked
or there is a virus on your machine and
then instructs you to download a
particular software
to mitigate that particular virus now
the malware will be in this software
that you will be downloading
and then a ransomware will be installed
and your data will be encrypted
screen lockers where locking uses
computers by preventing them
from logging in and displaying an
official looking message
you will see a screen saver once you
boot up which prevents you from
accessing the login page so it will not
allow you to log into your own machine
but it will give you a warning that your
data has been encrypted and you need to
connect to
a particular email address and send bit
to send bitcoins over there
uh to get a decryption key to access
your own data
and then the encrypting so ransomware
displays a message demanding payment in
return for the private
asymmetric key which is needed to
decrypt the symmetric keys for encrypted
file
so once your files have been encrypted
you might just have a blank screen in
front of you
where you'll receive a warning message
uh where it instructs you to pay up
a ransom in bitcoins or in some
cryptocurrency
to some particular digital e-wallet
which is not traceable
and once you make that payment they will
send you the decryption key and then you
can access your data
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more then talking about the
next question what is the difference
between an active and a passive cyber
attack
now when we talk about cyber attacks
cyber attack is a activity that is
caused by a malicious user who
wants to try to get access or do some
security incidents on the victim's
devices
so there are two ways that can happen
it's either in an active manner or a
passive manner in an active manner the
intruder attempts
to disrupt a network's normalcy modifies
data
and tries to alter the system's
resources so this is more active
where the attacker will proactively try
to
destroy the network so that
communications fail
or they might try to modify the data
where
we're using a ransom where they can
encrypt it or they might delete that
data using a virus
or steal that data using a trojan or
they might even
alter the data so that it is no longer
trustworthy whereas in a passive attack
the intruder intercepts data traveling
to a network here the intruder eavesdrop
but does not modify the message so
they're just listening in
they're just observing what is going on
they are not manipulating the data they
are not stealing anything
it's just that they are monitoring the
activity that's going on
the next question what is a social
engineering attack
now social engineering attack is a
people based attack the victim here
is the human by itself the vulnerability
also lies in the human
it may be executed through a computer
but
end of the day the calibrities of the
human so it is the art of manipulating
people
so that they end up giving up
confidential information
now we always read in the papers where
somebody got manipulated their passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out
right because they shared the otp with
someone or they shared
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people
will fall prey to this attack and share
this kind of personal information
to unknown people that is where the
social engineering attack comes in
creating that scenario which will ensure
that these people give out this
confidential information
now there are three categories in this
attack well the first one is a fishing
attack
second is a sphere fishing attack and a
third is a railing attack
now phishing attack is basically a
generic attack
it is targeted to the world at large
whoever falls prey to that
attack will be a victim whereas a spear
phishing attack
is a targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization
so there is a lot more research that
goes into spearfishing
where you analyze the victim you try to
figure out what their vulnerabilities
are
and your tailor make or you customize
the attack
to that particular vulnerability once
you have that attack you launch it
against those people
those people will then fall prey to this
attack
an availing attack is where you're
attacking
uh top-level executives so the c-level
executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people
so any of these people when they're
attacked it will be known as a
veiling attack next question what is man
in the middle attack now this is
something that we had touched based when
we talked about arp
where the arp poisoning attack needs to
be executed
to leverage a man in the middle attack
now in the man in the middle attack
the attacker attacking computer takes
the ip address of the client
unaware of this the server continues to
communicate with the attacker now
if you remember in a previous question
we have also talked about spoofing
so in this scenario uh attacker has
spoofed
their ip address to replicate themselves
as a
genuine client and now with that
spoofing in mind they might either
through
our poisoning attack or just because of
the spoofed ip address
become a man in the middle that means
that they are now
each dropping on the conversation
between the actual
client and the server by posing
themselves
as a server in this scenario the
attacker
is now a go between between the client
and the server and can eavesdrop and can
copy the data
if they want they can modify the data as
well so as you can see on the screen
the attacker becomes man in the middle
which means that they are now
eavesdropping on the conversation that
is happening between the client
and the server the next question who are
blackhead hackers and whitehead hackers
the main thing is the differentiation
between a blackhead hacker and a
whitetail hacker
now our blackhead hackers are skilled
individuals
who illegally hack into a system the
motive behind such an attack is mostly
for monetary gain
these individuals are known also known
as security crackers
now if you look at your criminal hackers
those who have malicious intent
those who do hacking for the intent of
personal gain
or for the matter of disruption the main
thing that black hat hackers
lack is authorization they are not
authorized to do the activity that they
are about to do
and they are going to get unauthorized
access to devices or to data
which is going to cause losses to the
organization involved whereas on the
other side a white hat hacker
are also known as ethical hackers these
are the individuals who discover
vulnerabilities in a computer network
and they help the organizations mitigate
these vulnerabilities
they help the organizations defend
themselves from black hat hackers
so the main difference between these two
types of hackers a black hat and a white
hat
is the intent and the authorization
so black hat hackers will have malicious
intent they will try to
personally gain from that attack from by
finding out vulnerabilities
they also will not have authorization to
conduct whatever activity they are doing
whereas on the other side whitehead
hackers will be hired by organizations
they will provide authorization for
certain activity that the white hat
hacker can do
to find out those vulnerabilities once
those vulnerabilities have been find out
found out by the white hat hacker
they will report it to the management
and guide them in
implementing security controls to
mitigate those vulnerabilities
the main difference between a black hat
and a white hat is the authorization
and the intent the next question what
are honey pots
now honey pots are a very interesting
device that can be introduced in a
network uh
these basically are decoy servers that
are implemented in a network to
attract the attention of attacker it is
there to lure an attacker
into uh attacking that particular device
thus creating a security blanket blanket
for the rest of the devices
so if an attacker has been able to
bypass a firewall
and is now trying to scan a particular
network when they scan they will come
across
various devices that are there in the
network they will then proceed to do a
vulnerability scan
on these devices the honeypot at that
point in time
will provide as an approve as an
attraction to these attackers because it
will
demonstrate some vulnerabilities to the
hacker
which will divert their attention so
these vulnerabilities are simulated on
these devices these actually do not
exist
but the moment the attacker then starts
interacting with the honeypot the
honeypot will identify
that as a malicious traffic and will
warm the one the administrator
about a possible attack that is going on
the administrator will then
investigate through the honeypot of what
activity is going on and then
reconfigure the security controls
to block the attacker or mitigate the
attack itself right
so it is more of a decoy server
uh that will showcase or simulate some
vulnerabilities
to an attacker thus to lure them and
safeguard the rest of the network these
are the 10 questions for cybersecurity
in the next video we'll be talking about
cryptography
the first question define cryptography
encryption
and decryption now cryptography
is used by security professionals to
scramble data
into non-readable format which is used
in securing that information
so it involves converting data from a
readable format into a non-readable
format
and then reversing it back to readable
format again for example
the word computer is now scrambled into
looking like
an unreadable format now if you look at
this word that it has been scrambled
into
it would be very difficult for a human
to figure out what the actual world was
now in this scenario we have taken an
algorithm where we have made
a shift of the alphabet
where we have added two alphabets the
current one so c plus 2
becomes e o plus 2 becomes q
m plus 2 becomes o so we have done a
shift of
2 and thus the key over here for this
algorithm is the alphabet plus 2. so any
person
who figures that out will be able to
unscramble this
and convert this back into readable text
the
fact of scrambling a readable text data
into something that is unreadable
by using a particular key is what
cryptography is all about
now as we discussed the decryption again
is
replacing the alphabet and taking it
further back by
two characters so e minus two becomes c
q minus two becomes o o minus 2 becomes
m and so on so forth so anybody who
knows this key
the shift key anybody will able to
decrypt this particular character so
this depends on the user if i want to
utilize alphabet plus
five then the spacing the shifting of
that character
will be the fifth character from that
particular character
and so on so forth the next question
what is the difference between cipher
text and clear text
cipher text refers to the text which is
encrypted and totally undesirable
the message received after decryption is
known as clear text this text is
comprehensible
so the word computer is clear text that
means that it has not been treated to
any cryptographic measures
it does what it is intended to be
however
if the moment we encrypt it that means
we scramble it into unreadable text
by using any of the algorithms that
we'll be looking at
that text is known as a cipher text and
without the key
this becomes unreadable the clear text
as discussed is the plain word that we
have utilized we are using the english
language in this instance
so the plain word computer is the clear
text once we add the encryption layer to
it
we get the cipher text to it
moving on to the next question what is a
block cipher
this refers to the method of encrypting
the plain message
block by block the plain message is
broken down into fixed size blocks and
then encrypted
now a block cipher is normally used for
data
that is stored so a data that is stored
on a hard disk and we want to encrypt
that data that is known as block
encryption or a block cipher so a block
cipher
is an algorithm that will allow you to
encrypt
data that is stored onto a hard disk so
in this example
we've got plain text which is 64 bits in
size
and we have added a layer of encryption
to it so plain text plus the key that we
have studied in the previous questions
and then the scrambled data out of it
which is unreadable
and thus encrypted then the next
question what is public key
infrastructure
now the public key infrastructure is a
set of policies which secures the
communication between a server and a
client it uses two cryptographic keys
public
and private so the infrastructure itself
is a set
of policies people procedures
and techniques which are standardized in
nature
and are globally accepted which allow us
to use digital certificates to encrypt
data
and decrypt the data at the other end
we use asymmetric encryption over here
which means that we are used two keys
one is a public key to encrypt and the
private key to decrypt
the other part of your encryption is a
symmetric encryption where the same key
is used to encrypt and the same key is
used to decrypt
now in a public key infrastructure
uh like i said we have standardized that
so in the standardizing part of it
these are the various players that have
been defined in the public key
infrastructure
the first is this user or the sender in
the scenario the one who requires
this digital signature to digitally sign
a particular transaction or a
communication
a registration authority with whom they
are going to register for
that particular key the certification
authority who issues that key
the verification authority who validates
the
key itself and the recipient who is
going to be the other party of that
particular transaction
so how is this utilized a sender or the
user who requires this
digital signature will request or apply
for a digital signature with the
registration authority
the registration authority would
validate the
genuinely of the user so they might do
some
identity verification or
proof of residence or something like
that once they've identified the
person and they have validated the
information
they will then send the request to the
certification authority
stating that the sender has been
validated and we can
and the certification authority can
issue the digital certificate
to the particular user they will
send the public key to the sender which
will be utilized by the sender
for further transactions so when the
sender
is going to sign some data and wants to
send it across to the recipient they
will use the public key to sign it
and send it across the recipient will
then
validate with the verification authority
to see if the data
the signed data is correct or not now
while the certification authority sends
the public key to the sender
the certification authority updates the
private key with the verification
authority
so whatever is signed by the sender uh
received by the recipient and they want
to validate it they will send it back to
the verification authority
the verification authority will validate
using the private key
once the private key is validated it
will then send
the ok signal back to the recipient thus
allowing the
validation of that particular
transaction
if the signature is tampered with or is
not the
very fiction authority is not able to
validate the signature it will then send
a denial
message back to the recipient and the
transaction will
not go through so the pki enables
trusted digital identities for people
so the pki grants secure access to
digital resources based on the
infrastructure that has been created
and the core of the pki is a
certification authority which ensures
that the trustworthiness of the digital
data is
ensured so going back to the previous
slide
these are the key players that have been
standardized in the
public key infrastructure the
certification authority is the authority
that issues the digital certificates
the validation authority is the one who
validates that digital certificate
moving on what is rsa
rsa is one of the first public key
crypto systems that is used for
secure data transmission it stands for
reverse xiaomi and edelman
now these are the three people who have
created this algorithm
rand rivest adi shamir and leonard
edelman
who are the inventors of this technique
it is a symmetric cryptography algorithm
which works on both public and private
keys
hence the encryption key is public and
the decryption key is kept
private now as we have discussed earlier
symmetric and asymmetric cryptography
symmetric cryptography is where the same
key is used to
encrypt and decrypt whereas asymmetric
cryptography is where there are two keys
to encrypt and decrypt the algorithm
what are the few alternatives to rsa now
rsa is an algorithm
that is used for encryption there are a
lot of other algorithms that can be
utilized
to alter or to scramble data depending
on your requirements
so in the previous question we have
studied and we have talked about what
rsa is it stands for uh reverse xiaomi
and adelma the three creators
of that particular algorithm but there
are a lot of alternatives
to this algorithm depending on how
secure you want that data to be
and some of them are listed here on your
screen
duo security octa google authenticator
and lastpass
lastpass is a password manager
so is dual security google authenticator
is something that we all utilize it is
an application
that we can download and store on our
mobile devices and we can set that up
to authenticate ourselves with certain
portals
so it issues a unique id
to us which once utilized will allow us
access to those particular portals
octa is an identity manager where you
have created different digital
identities
and you have assigned them certain
permissions and
based on your authentication mechanisms
octa will allow or disallow
access to those different applications
or different portals as you have
configured it so all four are
authorization authentication mechanisms
which can be used as alternatives to rsa
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more next question what are the
prime objectives of modern cryptography
and this is a very important question
because we've so far looked at what
cryptography is
and what public key infrastructure is
but what is the achievement out of it
why are we utilizing it
and what do we want to gain out of it so
the main
and the prime objectives of modern
cryptography are
as follows mentioned on your screen the
first one is confidentiality
the second one is non-repudiation third
one is authenticity
and the fourth one is integrity now if i
go back to the first one
confidentiality uh that is where i want
to
keep data confidential that means it
will only be visible to the authorized
users
right so here i've created a list of
people who have
deemed as authorized users and have
created a digital identity to them
and have given access controls to those
people now that is how confidentiality
is
ensured so when we want to keep data
confidential we create a list of users
who we are going to allow access to
certain resources
and we are going to define what access
controls are to be utilized what access
are allowed whether they
got an administrative access or user
level access and only those authorized
users
are going to be able to access these
resources that is how we maintain
confidentiality the next one is
non-repudiation non-reputation is the
prevention of denial of having been a
part of a particular transaction
so in the public key infrastructure that
we discussed where a digital signature
was utilized to sign
a particular transaction and then sent
to the recipient the sender would not be
able to deny
of having originated that transaction
because it was using
their digital certificate thus
non-reputation comes into the picture
uh one more example that we can have
here is
on our mobile phones when we use sms
short messaging service
and we send a message to uh to another
person
the person when they receive a message
the number is validated by the service
operator
and thus the sender cannot deny having
sent that message the sender at the same
time can have a delivery report sent to
them
uh from that the message was delivered
to the inbox of the recipient
and thus if the recipient denies having
received that message the delivery
report becomes proof
of having that message being delivered
to their inbox
thus both the parties cannot deny
of have a of being a part of that
particular transaction
then comes the part of authenticity
now in confidentiality we have created a
digital identity assigned into a
particular person
and we have given them digital
signatures where they cannot deny having
being a part of that transaction
but authenticity is the part where they
try to prove that they are who they
claim to be
so if i am claiming a digital identity i
have to
prove that i am that person who i am
trying to claim to be
and an example to that is when we go to
our gmail.com websites
it first asks us what is our username
our username is normally our email
address which
identifies the account that we are
trying to access right
so this account is confidential because
it is only authorized for a particular
person
and once they identify themselves by
identifying the email address
that's when the authentication part
comes into the picture where it asks for
the password
now it has never ever happened that we
just go onto gmail.com type in a
password and then it figures out which
account we are talking about
so the first step is always the
confidentiality part where we identify
which account we are talking about
and then we try to authenticate as the
owner of that particular account
by providing the appropriate password to
that account
if both of these match only then do we
get access to that account
and we are able to make uh whatever
transactions we want to make
now when we are making those
transactions non-reputation comes into
the place
where all our activities also being
logged so we have
identified our account we have
authenticated ourselves by providing the
password
so the proof is there that it is us who
are trying to access it
and then whatever activity we do send an
email receive an email delete something
attach something all of those activities
are logged
and stored as proof of what actions have
been done
so tomorrow if we deny having sent that
email gmail can still prove to us
through those logs that though that that
activity was done by us
and the fourth part is integrity which
ensures that the data received and sent
and
sent by the sender and received by the
recipient has not been modified
while in motion
so the integrity part is the
trustworthiness of that data that the
data has not been modified by any hacker
or any other
entity and is still trustworthy so these
are the four prime objectives of modern
cryptography once i have scrambled that
data
using my public's uh signature
it is only my private signature that is
going to decrypt it right
using these mechanisms i will be able to
achieve all these four aspects
of cryptography and security next
question
what is safer now safer stands for
secure and fast encryption routine
which is also a block cipher as we have
discussed previously
block cipher is a cipher that is used to
encrypt data that is stored
so it has a 64-bit block size and
byte-oriented algorithm
cipher's encryption and decryption
procedures are highly secure this
technology is widely used in
applications like digital payment card
so
when you're using your a digital
payment gateway to make transactions so
you have you've gone on to an online
portal
you want to purchase a particular item
and
then it takes you to another payment
gateway where you have to fill in your
credit card information sensitive
information like your
uh expiry dates cvv information
and then the otp or the password that
you have created for your particular
account now all of these need to be
secured
or highly secured based on pci dss which
is the payment card industry data
security standard
so these standards ensure that certain
protocols are utilized
to attain that level of security safer
is one of those block ciphers
that is used under the digital payment
gateway infrastructure
next question how does the public
infrastructure public key infrastructure
work
now we have already discussed this in
the previous diagrams
we have identified the key players the
certification authority
the registration authority the end user
who requires the digital certificate
the validation authority who's going to
validate it and then
the recipe and the end user with whom
the transaction is going to be
conducted so the first point here is the
request for the digital certificate is
sent to the registration authority
they validate it and then they okay to
the certification authority who then
process the request and the digital
certificate is issued to the person who
has requested it
so when the person wants to conduct that
transaction they use that
uh digital certificate to sign that
transaction with the end user
the end user validates that with the
validation authority
and once validated the transaction goes
through
and now the last question what is the
blowfish algorithm
it is a 64-bit symmetric encryption
algorithm so this is an algorithm that
uses the same
key to encrypt and the same key to
decrypt the same secret key is used to
encrypt and decrypt the messages
here the operations are based on
exclusive ors and additions to the on
32-bit words
the key has a maximum length of 448 bits
now this is a little bit technical
uh you might not want to go this
technical in an interview question you
just need to identify what the algorithm
is used for
so whether it is a symmetric algorithm
which means it uses the same key
or uh a symmetric algorithm
where it uses a public key to encrypt
and apply private key to
decrypt thus the blowfish algorithm is
just one more algorithm
which uses symmetric encryption to
encrypt and decrypt data
algorithms that we have seen rsa and
others that we have discussed
as far as the interview questions are
concerned what we need to remember is
uh which algorithms are symmetric which
algorithms are asymmetric
what do symmetric algorithms do and what
do unsymmetric uh symmetric algorithms
do
and we also look at block ciphers and
stream ciphers
block ciphers are utilized to encrypt
data that is stored
stationary data data rest and stream
ciphers
are utilized for data in motion while
they're being streamed
so ssl and tls is another algorithm that
comes into the picture
when you're looking at streaming data
that's it for this particular video i'll
see you in the next thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here